but I actually heard me of something in
comments I have a really embarrassing
story I felt well actually its online
you can see it of how I met Merrill
Street so embarrassing because I wasn't
prepared I feel like one soul should be
prepared when you turn around American
Street universe middle finger to you
actually here you a funny sort of like
me too you know if you're not prepared
how dare she be that good you scare
everybody like you know how do you have
a work ethic and all the talent that's
not fair yeah I was leaving a charity
event and I was going I was I was
performing it so I was I was I was
running out of some hotel in New York
City I was like and I'm running from
this event and I'm running down the hall
like book I was like power walk it was
like and up the escalator comes this
vision it's Meryl Streep and in
mid-stride so like this so midst I just
go oh I'm sorry I just grabbed you I'm
sorry I just grabbed you I apologize
you're my favorite person in the world
and then walking forward after I just
did that and then she walks past and she
just turns around it very sweetly goes
and you're one of my favorite people in
the world which is exactly what you'd
expect from the Meryl Streep right it's
exactly what you'd expect for the
perfection of Christ caressed my cheek
it's fine
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this